bonsoir nous sommes le 26 mai 2015 lors
du journal de la rédaction est dans
l'actualité locale le conseil
départemental des yvelines lance un
partenariat avec l'état et pôle emploi
en faveur de l'insertion
socioprofessionnelle les demandeur
d'emploi les plus fragiles bénéficieront
par exemple d'un accompagnement renforcé
la motion b est en tête dans le
département des yvelines avec 46,67 %
des voix les socialistes du département
elle n'approuve pas forcément l'action
du gouvernement il faudrait du
changement pour en parler la responsable
locale sera en plateau et puis est
depuis 2011 l'aéro club de versa et
proposait des baptêmes aux enfants
malades ou en difficulté
ce week-end vous l'avez vu la patrouille
de france étaient de la fête le festival
de cannes 2015 a donc livré son palmarès
la palme d'or revient à jacques audiard
pour deep and un film tourné dans la
cité el de la coudraie à poissy les
habitants ont été impliqués dans ce
tournage certains ont même fait la
montée des marches
on notera aussi que la région ile de
france à verser une subvention de 480
mille euros pour que cette histoire
d'une jeune femme fuyant la guerre
civile au sri lanka et qui trouvent
refuge en france puisse voir le jour
sortie prévue pour le grand public fin
août
ce n'est pas la première fois que ce
quartier yvelinois sert de décor au
septième art john travolta luc besson
puis roschdy zem s'y sont déjà installés
ces dernières années le conseil
départemental a donc présenté ce matin
sa politique en faveur de l'insertion
socioprofessionnelle une convention a
ainsi été signée avec pôle emploi
facilitant la coordination des services
l'insertion professionnelle dans les
yvelines va aussi s'articuler autour
d'activités est qu'une agence
d'insertion et la création d'une auto
école sociale mélanie poquet patrick
jacques de dixmude multiples signature
ce matin entre le conseil départemental
pôle emploi et l'état pour permettre une
meilleure coordination des services
départementaux et de pôle emploi
plusieurs signatures mais un seul but
l'insertion socioprofessionnelle des
personnes les plus en difficulté les
chômeurs longue durée
ces dix personnes qui ont
qui sont confrontés à des difficultés de
logement des difficultés sociales
diffuser de garde d'enfants des
personnes qui sont risque d'expulsion
par exemple ou des personnes sur des
problématiques de santé importantes et
1200 personnes devraient être
accompagnées d'ici l'été par les 17
employés de pôle emploi
associé à des binômes issue du conseil
départemental les yvelines ont vu une
très forte augmentation du nombre de
bénéficiaires du revenu de solidarité
active
autre cible de cette politique avec près
de 38 % en cinq ans le rsa représente 10
% du budget du département
j'ai pas de voiture j'habite en grande
couronne il n'y a pas de gars là où
j'habite
donc je peux pas trouver un emploi ou
bien comme j'ai pas d'emploi je peux pas
trouver un logement ou comme j'ai pas
d'emploi je peux pas acheter une voiture
et voilà et tout ça fait que on va
essayer d'apporter par réponse point
parfois mes réponses en même temps deux
autres initiatives ont été présentés ce
matin la création d'une auto école
sociale et le lancement d'activités une
agence des vingt emplois c'est du
personnel
de la collectivité mise à disposition
donc aujourd'hui l'agencé neuf personnes
au niveau de versailles mais on est en
train de constituer des équipes sur les
territoires pour qu'elle soit en
relation étroite avec les collectivités
avec les associations avec tous les
partenaires qui travaillent en direction
de la question de l'emploi activités
aura une voire deux équipes sur saint
quentin en yvelines
pôle emploi a recensé 80 7880 chômeurs
dans les yvelines pour le mois de mars
2015 l'invité politique de ce 26 mai
sandrine gambon soir sa première fédéral
du parti socialiste dans les yvelines on
va commenter avec vous et les résultats
des votes internes à votre formation
votre qui concernait en france en fin de
semaine dernière 131000 militants à jour
de leur cotisation ils devaient choisir
l'un des quatre textes déterminant la
ligne du parti c'est la motion à qui l'a
emporté apporté par le premier
secrétaire sortant jean christophe
cambadélis en tête avec 60% des
suffrages la motion b dit celle des
fondeurs pour faire court avec le député
christian paul est soutenu par liv
lingua benoît hamon par vous également
elle totalise 29 % avant de regarder le
détail dans les yvelines les résultats
de votre fédération déjà votre sentiment
sur ce résultat national il n'y a pas de
déception
seulement 30 % 30 % c'est un mambo socle
pour la gauche du parti
donc pas de déception après on voit bien
qu'il ya aussi un réflexe légitimiste
dents dans le parti socialiste comme
partout et qu'un certain nombre de
mythes en ont pas osé aller jusqu'à même
si et beaucoup d'émotion à l ambition d
partager nos idées n'ont pas osé passer
le rubicon pas peut-être par peur d'une
déstabilisation qui était fictive en
fait par rapport justement à l'opinion
nationale il ya une participation de 50%
des militants on est à peu près sur 70
mille votants résultat du vote interne
il ya un décalage quand on garde la cote
de popularité du président du premier
ministre de l'action du gouvernement il
ya un décalage il ya une forte
contestation
finalement envers ce gouvernement envers
le président
envers l'action la politique qui est
menée et finalement les militants
socialistes soutiennent cette action
l'idée c'est de soutenir globalement un
gouvernement qui est celui que nous
avons choisie en 2012 de lui laisser le
temps sur l'ensemble du quinquennat de
faire l'action qui pour lesquelles il a
été élu et nous on considère qu' on est
en soutien mais qu'il faut aussi
abandonné poussé pour réorienter un
certain nombre de sujets justement pour
répondre à ce que vous évoquez c'est à
dire une forme d'interrogation d'un
certain nombre de français notamment des
électeurs de gauche
donc on entend ça et c'est aussi pour ça
que moi en particulier j'avais choisi de
signer la motion cette motion e bay et
motif de satisfaction pour vous 47000
47% des militants dans les yvelines
soutiennent cette motion b la motion a
ne fait que 39% 47%
les opposants ceux qui soutiennent la
motion à diront que finalement c'est pas
tant que ça alors que vous étiez bien
implanté dans le département sauf que
bien implanté ça fait que deux ans que
je suis à la tête de cette fédération
donc en deux ans on a travaillé on a
fait un travail de conviction
donc nous on est évidemment très
satisfait ce une traditionnellement une
fédération plus tôt rocardienne donc
aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'elle s'est
un petit peu déporté et qu'on vous
disiez les opposants moi j'ai pas
d'opposante sein du parti socialiste et
des camarades voilà on va m'en donner on
démarre on est un rapport de force qui
s'établit et puisque les militants
tranchent et après évidemment on
travaille ensemble
aujourd'hui tout est apaisée justement
avec ses résultats maintenant que chacun
s'est exprimé à exposer ses motifs de
satisfaction ou non ils allaient
travailler ensemble bien sûr qu'on
travaille ensemble on ne partage des
valeurs communes
et on a des objectifs communs il reste
une dernière étape qu'est l'élection du
premier fédéral puisqu'on a mois de juin
7,7 dernières élections donc forcément
là aussi s'il ya plusieurs candidats il
y aura des bas mais après de toute façon
la logique c'est de travailler tous
ensemble ils et comment ça tu la
fédération des yvelines justement avec
ce résultat qui qui entérine un petit
peu donc l'action que vous menez et qui
est un peu par nos positions mais en
tout cas qui souligne les ailes et les
incohérences les résultats qui ne
fonctionne pas toujours du gouvernement
comment vous positionner aujourd'hui en
opposition non pas comme ça parce que en
réalité quand on aura les réunions au
niveau national sur un certain nombre de
sujets on est d'accord quand on regarde
la motion à la portée par exemple le
fait que pour le cic il fallait des
compensations 100 % des militants ont
voté pour qu'il ya des compensations
demandées entend paix sur le cic donc
nous on sera là simplement pour dire
voilà vous avez écrit des choses dans la
motion a sur lequel nous aussi on est
d'accord mais c'était pas que des mots
il va falloir aussi que ça rentre en
application mais quand françois hollande
dit à l'issue du résultat que cela donne
de la stabilité à l'action du
gouvernement c'est alain stabilité mais
je pense que ça aussi permis par exemple
qu'il y ait d oreille plus attentive sur
les propositions comme celle que vient
de porter venoix monde sur le burn out
dans les entreprises ça permet aussi de
dire voilà il ya d'autres voies qu'il
faut entendre qu'il faut peut-être
prendre en compte et je pense que ça
permet d'avoir une écoute différente
quels sont les points aujourd'hui
justement très clairement qu'ils posent
problème en tout cas qu'ils font
scission au sein du parti socialiste ont
causé une commotion motion émotion b si
vous regardez les textes y en a pas
parce qu'en fait la motion à aller vous
allez faire une seule motion alors fallu
la motion a finalement choisi de
remettre l'essentiel des fondamentaux de
ce qu'ils avaient par exemple dans le
discours du bourget mais après la
question c'est la stratégie
comment le prochain premier solitaire
fait en sorte que ce qui est écrit dans
la motion puissent irriguer jusque à la
tête de l'état c'est ça aujourd'hui qui
est l'enjeu
après on voit bien qu'il ya une petite
minorité mais qui ne sait pas compter
dans le parti autour d'eux que du maire
de lyon et de gens comme jean marie le
guen qui eux sont beaucoup plus on va
dire radicaux dans leur position
économique mais les 106 s'avère pas
comme fondeur aujourd'hui dans un
mouvement de fond d'heure ben non
puisque enfin moi je me suis toujours
trouvé que le mot était inappropriée et
puis finalement quand on regarde le
contenu d'émotion on sait plus trop qui
est fondeur un mot sur les résultats
aussi du vote vendredi dernier dans le
département la direction fédérale
sortons donc votre direction était
soutenu à plus de 63 % malgré les
résultats des précédentes élections va
rappeler que beaucoup de mairies ont
basculé à droite les agglomérations
comme saint quentin en yvelines
également et qu'il n'y a pas un seul élu
de gauche socialiste au conseil
départemental
malgré tout on soutient votre action ce
n'est pas lié les deux premiers c'est
dire que si c'était la fédération qui
fait gagner
seules les élections les qui lui faisait
perdre ça ce serait ça donne ça serait
donné un grand pouvoir quand même aux
premiers fédéraux
malheureusement ce n'est pas le cas où
heureusement je ne sais pas mais on sait
bien que c'est le contexte national la
politique nationale qui qui fait que les
gens votent pas les gens ils ne votent
pas par rapport à ce qui existe comme
représentants départementaux dans le 2
mai parti socialiste aujourd'hui dans
les yvelines va être en reconquête ne
serait-ce que son ancien ça c'est autre
chose
commencer comment on accompagne le
travail de reconquête
mais ça ne peut passer par la fédération
seul c'est l'ensemble du gouvernement
c'est l'ensemble des législateurs aussi
des députés des sénateurs et bien sûr du
parti avec sa direction nationale
le congrès de poitiers qui va se
dérouler déroulée début juin va se
passer dans le calme ou est ce que vous
pensez qu'il ya encore des voies qui
vont s'élever le parti ces lycéens un
parti on débat on est toujours donc ceux
qui aiment le démarrage de l'autre en
public aussi tous ceux qui sont qui ont
envie de s'engager à venir dans ce type
de partie parce que ankara qui attire
souvent les partis politiques mais se
trouve que
c'est des lieux voilà on confronte des
idées or parfois oui c'est pas une
manière de débattre qui peut être
parfois un peu virulente mais dérouter
mais en même temps c'est ça fait partie
de la défense de la démocratie c'est
plutôt sain il ya des débats donc il y
aura des débats jusqu'à poitiers et
encore après mais par contre on est
respectueux des uns des autres
en tout cas dans la fédération et je
pense que vous parliez du rapport
fédéral qui a été abordé adoptez assez
largement en faveur d'activités
je pense qu au moins tous les mêmes
s'ils ne soutiennent pas tous mon action
et l'action de la fédération sortante
tout le monde reconnaît qu'il ya un
respect et que le débat se passe dans
des bonnes conditions
le débat vous le disiez maps ou six
poursuivre après ce congrès de poitiers
ne serait ce que parce que derrière il
ya les élections régionales vous êtes
conseiller sortant
justement vous étiez sur la liste de
jean paul huchon qui ne sera pas
candidat là aussi on en a beaucoup parlé
dans les médias avec ces débats que vous
évoquez c'est claude bartolone qui a
présenté la liste a priori pour les
socialistes vous serez sur cette liste
j'en sais rien je la layette rabat avait
déjà discuté
oui un jeu en tant que premier fédéral
je discute avec eux avait claude
bartolone
maintenant toutes les semaines puisqu'on
a des comités de campagne qui qui vont
se mettre en place toutes les semaines
la consigne qui l'a donné c'est des
listes à l'image de l'île de france
renouvelée avec toute une nouvelle
génération qui représente l'avenir aussi
pour nos territoires
donc on essaiera de faire une liste à la
hauteur de ces enjeux là et de cette
demande qu'est-ce que vous serez sur
cette liste et je serai candidate pour
être sur la liste
et ce sera tranché et ce sera alors
normalement début juillet début juillet
merci 100 millions au groupe d'être venu
en plateau la motion b celle de la
branche gauche de la gauche
on va dire pas des frondeurs dans tout
cas de la gauche de la gauche est donc
en tête dans les yvelines je vous
rappelle aussi que benoît hamon le
député sera l'invité du prochain café
politique sur tv fils émission à
découvrir dès la semaine prochaine à la
veille du congrès socialiste de poitiers
nous reprenons le cours de l'actualité
locale avec ce week end la spa qui a
organisé ses journées portes ouvertes
cette année nouveau slogan on a tous une
chance d'être adoptés l'occasion de
parler de l'adoption de tous les animaux
même ceux qui sont blessés ou malades et
d'encourager les futurs propriétaires à
se rendre dans les refuges florane
parfait patrick jacques de dixmude
des chiens des chats de tout âges de
toutes conditions et tous aptes à
l'adoption dans ce refuge et à plaisir
ils sont plus de 150 pensionnaires à
attendre de nouveaux maîtres
bienveillant germé vous aujourd'hui avec
son fils pour rencontrer zigzag une
petite femelle bull dog âgé de six ans
on a regardé un petit peu cette semaine
pour trouver un petit compagnon à nos
chaînes qui vient déjà de la spa iavi
mois et on a regardé sur le site de la
spa on a vu ces petits c petit
bouledogue ces petits congénères de la
même race et on est venu les voir les
présenter voir si éventuellement ils
peuvent avoir un avenir ensemble on
aurait pu passer par les annonces
classiques par les éleveurs ou quoi que
ce soit mais autant leur donner une
deuxième chance à ces boules de poils
certains animaux sont ici depuis déjà
longtemps pour les journées portes
ouvertes de la spa souhaite faire passer
un message de tolérance et de tendresse
ou adoptant le slogan de cette année on
a tous une chance d'être adoptés on a
aussi des vieux animaux dans les refuges
on a des animaux bord on a des trois
pattes ils ont eux aussi le droit
d'avoir un foyer donc ils sont pas moins
intéressants que les autres donc voilà
cette nouvelle est une petite idée
appuyée en fait pour pour leur trouver
des foyers parce qu'ils le méritent eux
aussi
trente et un chien 54 chat et un lapin
ont été adoptées ce week end
il reste encore plus d'une centaine de
petits compagnons ils méritent tous une
deuxième chance et n'attendent que vous
au refuge de la spa a plaisir à
l'occasion de la journée nationale de la
santé du pied le 21 mai dernier l'union
française pour la santé du pied à
organiser des journées de dépistage à
travers toute la france quelques minutes
pour rencontrer gratuitement cette fois
ci un pédicure podologue et pour
comprendre d'où proviennent certaines
douleurs comment les traiter également
mélanie poker
on a tendance à les cacher mais eux
aussi méritent toute notre attention
le pied s'entretient pour être en bonne
santé beaucoup de gens négligent
il ya beaucoup de consultations de
dernière minute en urgence des ongles
incarnés des durillons qui sont là
depuis des années qu'ils sont très
douloureux qui empêche de travailler ou
de faire du sport correctement et du
coup consultés se rend compte qu'en fait
injuste en lance donc une écurie sont
soulagés pour éviter ces situations
l'union française pour la santé du pied
propose depuis 2003 les dépistages
gratuits dans les yvelines c'est la
troisième année que des podologues
participent à la journée nationale une
séance chez un spécialiste permet de
dépister mycoses ongle incarné problèmes
cutanés
mais aussi problèmes d'arthrose au
niveau des genoux hanches ou encore du
dos ont pu poser un diagnostic sur
l'appareil locomoteur
donc c'est à dire que le pied vraiment
relations entre appareil locomoteur dans
son ensemble c'est à dire le genou le
dos la hanche
même au niveau cervical et on travaille
on a des éléments de semaine on peut
travailler sur ses articulations et
soulager des pathologies au veau d'or en
2012 seulement 30% des français
consulter un podologue en 2014
ils sont 41% bon moi j'ai pas de soucie
vraiment particulier donc voila mais
j'ai eu des conseils concernant parce
que je ne vais jamais chez le pédicure
et apparemment il faut y aller une fois
par an pour moi c'est pas vraiment la
prévention l'un l'occurrence puisque
disons je suis sam handicap énormément
pour marcher depuis à peu près un mois
donc c'est plus que de la prévention on
jeudi l'année prochaine j'espère que je
reviendrai pour de la prévention
selon une étude de l'observatoire
national de la santé 65 % des français
ont mal au niveau des pieds mais une
consultation chez un podologue coûte 27
euros et n'est remboursé que
partiellement par la sécurité sociale
depuis 2011 l'aéro club de versailles
permettent aux enfants hospitalisés dans
la région d'oublier quelques instants à
la maladie des baptêmes de l'air sont
organisés pour eux et ce week end petit
bonus avec la présence de la patrouille
de france
il est midi en ce samedi 23 mai tous les
regards se tournent vers le ciel comme
soudain
les alpha jet de la patrouille de france
feront leur apparition au dessus de
l'aérodrome de saint cyr l'école une
démonstration à l'attention d'une
cinquantaine d'enfants venus en famille
s'évader du milieu hospitalier qu'il
fréquente au quotidien ou de leurs
difficultés sociales situé route ces
textes et registre et en vidéo est là
depuis 2011 année de son centenaire
l'aéro club de versailles organise des
journées comme celle-ci les baptêmes de
l'air sont chaîne grâce aux pilotes
bénévoles et bien au début j'avais un
peu peur et puis après ça allait mais
après on s'y habitue vite
les sponsors privés participent au
financement de ces journées un baptême
coûte une centaine d'euros le prix d'un
souvenir inoubliable pour les enfants
comme pour les moniteurs
on a commencé en 2011 en passant le
faire qu'une année que pour le
centenaire et les enfants nous donne
tellement quand on les voit descend de
l'avion leurs yeux qui brille le sourire
et ses onze iba si je peux donner un
petit peu de bonheur à ses enfants
on va continuer un petit peu à le faire
on va pas arrêter et donc à éclair au
club on a décidé de continuer alors
quand c'est des enfants handicapés ou
des fois autiste qui ne parlent pas que
quand ils sont là on se demande même
pourquoi on les a fait venir et les
faire voler mais quand ils descendent de
l'avion vous les voyez les yeux briller
et puis qui viennent qui vous font un un
câlin qui vous en laisse voilà le monde
vous appartient quoi que vous en donnez
le monde près de 2000 enfants de la
région déjà bénéficié de cette opération
ils seront encore plus nombreux à la fin
de l'été puisque deux nouvelles journées
sont déjà programmés et cg choir pas
perd assez génial surtout que ça fait
deux fois on vient on est venu en 2013
donc là voilà c'est la deuxième fois la
première fois je suis monté avec elle
j'ai eu droit aussi à mon petit diplôme
et puis elle est super contente donc si
génial on passe aux sports à présent les
finales du championnat de france
scolaire d'ultimate était programmée
mardi mercredi à trappes pour la
deuxième fois après 2009 au total plus
de 200 collégiens et lycéens venus de
toute la france ont foulé les pelouses
des stades gilbert chance à acro berg
ravaux on écoute christophe pillet
directeur adjoint de l'urss de
versailles le responsable de ce tournoi
et nous nos visiteurs de ce plafond cm
avec un recul que là j'ai fait que tu
puisses et qui viennent de partout en
france ça va de nîmes lille
le strasbourg nancy
beaucoup d'équipés de la région
d'orléans tours nantes angers dijon au
niveau scolaire c'est le plus gros
événement au niveau du sport scolaire
on travaille en lien avec la fédération
française qui a aussi eu le week-end
dernier à sablé sur sarthe le
championnat les couples juniors au
national donc ça fait partie des 8 3 4
événements les plus importants niveaux
jeunes sur le territoire
chez les collégiens c'est
l'établissement de luzarches implanté
dans le val d'oise qui est devenu
champion de france la ville
bourguignonne de talent a quant à elle
remporté le prix du fair play dans la
catégorie des lycéens c'est beaugency
située dans le département du loiret qui
s'est illustrée en remportant le trophée
de champion de france et du fair-play
prochaine édition l'année prochaine en
vendée
le free en guise trophy un raid
interentreprises qui réunit par équipes
valides handicapés s'est élancé samedi
matin devant le château de versailles 22
équipes et qui vont devoir parcourir 800
kilomètres qui nous séparent de brest un
moyen de faire évoluer les mentalités ce
week end les participants se sont
aventurés à travers neauphle-le-château
houdan ou encore dreux vous pouvez
suivre leurs péripéties en temps réel
sur le site internet de l'événement
pas de vague pour la piscine en plein
air de te rappelles l'état de
l'équipement des de l'île de loisirs ne
permet pas de réunir les conditions de
sécurité nécessaires des dalles de
carrelage se décolle une enquête doit
permettre de déterminer s'il s'agit
d'une malfaçon ou d'un mal plus profond
des travaux de rénovation ayant été
menées ces dernières années
si les dirigeants espèrent une
réouverture l'an prochain l'avenir du
site semble compromis son entretien
coûte cher le site rapporte peu
communauté d'agglomération départements
seraient favorables à sa fermeture
définitive
que pensez vous de cette décision alors
que le centre nautique de maurepas et
lui aussi pour l'instant définitivement
fermé c'est notre question du jour vos
réponses oui je sais que cette piscine
elle pose les problèmes en était
effectivement il est très souvent fermés
en étais-je et j'ai constaté ça dans le
passé sans lacets chaotique en termes
d'ouverture et de dispositions pour les
citoyens il faut bien qu'elles soient
rénovés je suppose c'est un peu dommage
que ce soit réparé au moment d'aider des
vacances scolaires quoi je trouve ça
bizarre de fermer une piscine l'été
c'est sûr que c'est dommage pour les
enfants qui n'ont pas la possibilité
peut-être vont-ils se reporter sur une
autre piscine les gens vont des enfants
qui peuvent pas partir en vacances si je
pense que ça a une incidence importante
je pense que les travaux si c'est pas
des crêpes des travaux qui peuvent poser
problème en fin ou des catastrophes ou
des enfants qui se font mal je pense
qu'effectivement les travaux pour aller
faire au mois de septembre mais papa en
juillet août
c'est pas logique quoi faire du journal
prochaine édition demain aux mêmes
horaires tout de suite le 7-8 sport avec
miquel et demi d'euros très bonne soirée